hoje
quarenta anos eu tive conta
com a ciência dura
na área da física não é isso que a
beatriz nos falam em outra área
hum há dez anos em 2003 quando me
afastei da universidade
eu já trabalhava em escultura no ateliê
livre de porto alegre e também estava
inscrito e fazia oficinas de desenho
desenho de observação mas até desenhava
razoavelmente bem mas não estava muito
contente com aquilo preocupado em
encontrar um caminho no desenho
contemporâneo um desenho altamente não
convencional que eu queria e um dia
assistindo um recital de violão e tchelo
lá no solar dos câmara
eu tive uma ideia e anotei até no
programa do recital
por isso eu tenho esse registro não
registro mais antigo dessa idéia até
escrito a fazer bolhas de sabão
carregadas com o pigmento e estoura
lançou o papel é vocês têm aí com não é
uma bolha é um registro fotográfico de
uma bolha na seci nepa unip disse o
magrinho
é isso aí note a beleza disso na
primeira parte e duas nas palestras
nós nos emocionamos também se mostra
bastante mas desejam as pequenas
loucuras que a gente pode ter casa como
é que a gente pode se emocionar com isso
aí fica todo arrepiado quando vê isso eu
saí correndo para pegar minha cama
nezinho para fotografar o sol entrou no
pela janela do meu ateliê a apoia
funcionou com um espelho côncavo curva
com um condensou a lua sobre o fenômeno
físico na minha frente uma maravilha
daquelas
é uma coisa incrível né
e ó a bolha já desenhou há algo ali no
papel vocês podem ver e eu eu nessa
minha procura pelo desenho eu tinha uma
eu tenho a minha escultura
ela já se baseava em equilíbrio e leveza
sempre procurei da leveza ao meu
trabalho ea minha busca era por leveza e
eu não estava pensando em retratar as
bolhas no meu trabalho
as bolhas aparecem em gravuras e
pinturas há séculos pintores famosos
usam quando fazem as suas bonitas né
falando sobre a feminilidade da nossa
vida as bolhas de sabão são as coisas
mas eu ro maravilha eu consegui então
[Música]
utilizando as bolhas carregar o pigmento
até o papel e fazer elas trabalharem as
bolhas que era um figuravam nos quadros
agora começar a trabalhar num desenho
pra mim foi uma maravilha um caminho
assim de diferente né pra mim então
subitamente essa bolha que já tinha
desenhado há algo no papel ela estourou
e fez um desenho mais delicada ainda ao
redor né
e deixou um anel de pequenas bolinhas
que continuarão desenhando então é é a
gente desculpa mas eu fiquei emocionado
[Risadas]
eu não sei é isso eu tinha conseguido um
tem céu mais leve que eu podia conseguir
ter o algo mais leve que eu não usei
planeta não use pincel real não é não
sei lá pensamos em nada e tinha um
desenho no papel de ser a maravilha né
as bolhas foi pincel mais leve que eu
consegui então o desenho 10 por exemplo
estão vendo com esse tamanho todo mas na
realidade ele tem dois sentimos um papel
que elas linhas são muito delicadas
muito leves eu estava de novo
trabalhando com a leveza que é o que eu
procuro sempre tenho seis ou sete linhas
de trabalho trabalho as culturas sempre
sempre a leveza da presente né
agora esse processo
ele tem a minha intenção de fazer um
certo desenho tem muita experimentação
porque eu tenho que trabalhar com
soluções vale as funções
eu tive que pesquisar tintas tive que
pesquisar a papéis diferentes e tal
então é tem muita experimentação né e
muito a caso
a bolha a imagem que vocês viram aqui é
uma coisa estática mas quando vocês
olham uma bolha de sabão na superfície
da tem muito movimento tem correnteza os
vórtices de coisas assim e com o
pigmento fica mais visível ainda quando
a bolha toca o papel ela imprime o
desenho que está naquele instante ali em
baixo mas sem esperar um pouquinho mais
o desenho já vai ser diferente
então tem uma outra coisa que é
introduzida aí que a aleatoriedade o
acaso né que é um processo muito
desejado em arte contemporânea hoje em
dia não
então vamos adiante
isso aqui por exemplo da empresa da
medicina uma guerra uma gravura esta
minha amiga quando viu isso aí
rogério que fizesse o fundo do meu olho
isso aí parece uma fotografia no fundo
de olho na medicina e então as coisas
são
a aí quando eu fiz uma exposição em 2008
é eu tínhamos 300 400 desenhos onde o
usava bolhas praticamente do mesmo
tamanho ea fazendo desenhos
sucessivamente são desenhos 6 por 100
centímetros e uma pequena coleção de uma
12 mostra pra vocês como eu tento fazer
o mesmo desenho mas sempre diferente né
aleatoriedade está aí
na exposição as pessoas viram embriões
galáxias n coisas foi uma maravilha
enquanto humana e vocês vejam o espirro
às vezes sai pra esquerda sai pra cima
as bolhas são minhas parceiras desde
então para desenhar mas elas são muito
temperamentais eu quero fazer uma coisa
e às vezes elas fazem uma coisa
completamente diferente né
é uma coisa aqui tem uma outra cartela
eu é um problema quando se faz uma
exposição como vai expor na desenhos tão
delicados quer dizer se você emoldurar
botar um vidro na frente você mata onde
assim você tem que usar tem que expor
sem vidro que eu essas coleções e well
eu fui eu me lembrei que podia usar
talvez coisas que os laterias não né
então comprei essas coisas e cabia
direitinho 12 desenhos nessa capela né
ginou vocês venha tentei fazer bolhas no
mesmo tamanho
claro que essas aí todas elas foram
classificadas pela minha mulher mas tem
uma classificação científica ela também
é da área de ciência e também da arte e
aí são todos do mesmo tipo mas eu tento
fazer igual mas não consigo elas são
temperamentais mesmo tem jeito a em 2008
eu fiz um eu tinha muitos muitos
desenhos feitos em uma turma de artistas
muito jovens que tinham um atelier
experimental que eu considerava o templo
desenho contemporâneo eu ia lá nas
mensagens dele sempre e tal e isso me
convidaram foi uma honra para mim ser
convidado por eles inclusive depois me
confidenciaram foi a primeira vez que
foi uma decisão unânime dos todos os
integrantes atender combinar uma pessoa
puxa vida pra mim foi incrível e eu fiz
uma exposição e um dos trabalhos dessa
exposição
tinha 12 cartelas dessas ou seja 12
meses 12 uma grosa de desenhos quer que
sabe o que é uma grosa a antigamente no
meu tempo de guri se comprar uma grosa
de lapso
o cara do armazém então disputou uma
grosa de desenhos e assim de novo teve a
música eu gosto muito violão clássico
eu tinha um pino era o título desta
exposição
o título é botar no e estava escutando o
violão clássico cd de um grande
violonista e daí a pouco está tocando
variações sobre um tema de mozar do sol
e em cima da mesa da vontade desses
desenhos de bocha aí chamei de micro
variações sobre um tema e foi o título
da exposição tá nessa exposição
surpreendeu a turma e tal e no ano
seguinte na época do açorianos recebeu
uma indicação de artista revelação que é
dada pra jovens artistas e puxa 60 e
poucos anos jovem artista ótimo sentir
renovada medicina ficou lá só eu e e
acabaram que recebeu açorianos esta
revelação foi incrível
agora vou falar de uma outra coisa que
me deixou toda arrepiada emocionado
quando houve realmente aqui eu tenho
três bolhas desenhando sobre o papel
vocês vêem o desenho sobre o papel agora
olhem no espaço que vocês vêem dois
arcos de tinta preta
são dois sacos de link do espaço
vocês têm um desenho sobre o papel e um
desenho no espaço acima do papel no
ranking
eu nunca tinha visto isso eu continuo
sem ver isso aí não é um desenho esse é
um registro fotográfico de um desenho
efêmero que sumiu quando as bolhas
evaporaram eu fiz diversos desses que
sumiram
eu digo puxa mais uma maravilha sair
correndo buscar minha câmera né
eu tenho que pelo menos fotografá lo
aqui eu tenho sete bolhas desenhando fui
colocando diligentemente uma depois da
outra em contato mesmo que elas são
sociáveis não correm uma da outra se
junto
e formam esse desenho maravilhoso no
papel e esse desenho no espaço de novo é
efêmero né
sumiu quando as bolhas evaporaram
diferente 4 bolhas desenhando agora tem
13 em contato lá e tem uma coluna
vertical de nanquim na linha onde as
três se encontram em uma pequena bolha
piramidal não é ali no meio tem um
desenho no espaço acima do papel quando
as bolhas se foram
ficou o desenho sobre o papel
esse desenho tem 23 centímetros de
tamanho zelo vão desenhar isso aí com
esses tons de cinza e tal né
não dá não dá a criança tem que ficar
preguiçoso e deixar as parceiras fazer
pra ele né
é isso que são parceiras maravilhosa
aqui é um desenho feito com 5 bolhas que
explodiram acima do papel vão tocar o
papel há uns grande cientista carol
mencionar califórnia ele o cientista
observou isso num curto espaço de tempo
as bolhas de sabão passam por todas as
etapas da nossa vida
elas nascem crescem e se desenvolvem sem
envelhecem e depois de um certo tempo
nasce morre desaparece e eu esse
processo eu usei a vida de muitas
parceiras
mas aqui tem um pouco de cor tem 34
golos tem gente que viu supernovas
planetas e tal
a imaginação é livre
aqui com uma variedade de desenhos que é
possível nas minhas parceiras são muito
competentes realmente são muito
competentes
reconhecer a aqui vocês tenham fins
primeiro uma bolha a laranjada e depois
depositem uma bolha preta em cima ea
interação da segunda com a primeira
dessa modificação chegou até separar
tinta laranja separou um pouco vermelho
do então existem coisas que levam a um
maravilhamento eu fico maravilhado às
vezes com o resultado enquanto continuar
em maravilhando com com isso aí eu vou
continuar fazendo isso é uma coisa que
eu aprendi com a minha mãe ea minha mãe
às vezes acordava de madrugada
rogério vem cá correndo de uma coisa não
sai a correr um dia lá no terraço e
olhava de um cometa no céu
eu aprendi a me maravilhar com as coisas
da natureza e tudo né
é uma coisa que a gente tem esse custo
contém cultivar é o que eu gostaria de
encerrar a arte contemporânea as
fronteiras da arte contemporânea são
muito difusa se vocês forem ver as
exposições vão surpreender coisas que
vocês bom mas isso não é a arte é isso
ea gatinha é muito difícil dizer mas que
bom que não sabemos o que é a arte
porque continuamos com a dúvida e
continuamos trabalhando o dia que eu
souber o que é
não vamos trabalhar mais não precisa não
tem mais motivação mas tem um grande
artista brasileiro hélio oiticica que
tem um pensamento que eu gosto muito
eu vou encerrar com ele a arte é um
exercício experimental de liberdade
obrigado
[Aplausos]